hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the most
interesting and short discussions in
Friedrich Nietzsche's genealogy of
morals has to do with punishment and in
it he asks about the difference between
the origin and the purpose of punishment
this is primarily in the second essay
the second part of the work and you find
it mainly in chapter well it's
concentrated in chapter 12 and chapter
13 but there's a lot of things going on
in the earlier chapters that that deal
with this as well so first off can we
say that Nietzsche has a theory of
punishment and in the modern sense
there's a lot of people out there who
have theories of punishment and if you
take a criminal justice class you take
you know a philosophy of Punishment
class or philosophy of crime or anything
like that then you're invariably going
to be introduced to things like a
deterrence theory of punishment and
incapacitation theory of punishment a
you know retributive or retribution arey
theory of punishment there's a lot of
different things out there and they're
often presents it as if well this is the
main idea behind punishment this is why
we punish and generally along with that
goes the the assumption that unless
you're punishing for that reason you're
not actually punishing rightly so these
are normative theories as well as just
merely explanatory theories about
punishment about imposing force on
somebody against their will for some
sort of offense whether it be an offense
against oneself an offense against the
society an offense against sort of mores
or something like that so doesn't eat
you have a theory of punishment like
that not exactly as a matter of fact
Nietzsche is really presenting a
challenge to any of these types of
theories of punishment in part because
he's saying those would all be matters
of purpose those would all be
discussions in which you're really
concerned with the point of punishing
why it is that we punish and the reason
generally you'd be doing that is so that
you could justify punishment to somebody
else
or to say we should restrict punishment
in certain ways you know for instance if
your utilitarian if you hold the view
that any sort of punishment is
essentially oriented towards the future
towards imposing certain restrictions on
people showing them certain things so
that you'll you'll cut down on the
amount of crime and the amount of
unhappiness in society thereby you have
a particular theory of punishment and
Nietzsche would say you're actually
misunderstanding the purposes the
possible purposes of punishment in part
because there could be multiple yes
almost you know
and possibilities for why we should
punish somebody he's more interested in
the origin of punishment and tracing
things back to to that so let's before
we actually get into that though let's
look at a certain passage this just
gives you an idea of just how many
possible purposes there could be to
punishment so he says to give an idea of
how uncertain how supplemental how
accidental the meaning of punishment is
and how one in the same procedure can be
employed interpreted adapted two ends
that differ fundamentally ends our
purposes I sat down here the pattern
that has emerged from consideration of
relatively few chance instances so he's
not saying these are all the reasons
that people say they punish these are
just a few if you sort of grab at random
a few purposes that people would adduce
for why why we might punish punishment
is a means of rendering harmless of
preventing further harm punishment --is
recompense to the injured party for the
harm done rendered in any form
punishment is the isolation of a
disturbance of equilibrium so as to
guard against any further spread of the
disturbance punishment is a means of
inspiring fear of those who determine
and execute the punishment punishment is
a kind of repayment for the advantages
that the criminal has enjoyed hitherto
punishment is the expulsion of a
degenerate element punishment is a
festival namely as the rape and mockery
of a finally defeated enemy punishment
as the making of a memory whether for
him who suffers the punishment so-called
improvement or for those who witness its
execution punishment is payment of a fee
stipulated by the power that protects
the wrongdoer from the excesses of
revenge you know sometimes we punish
people according to this view we punish
people instead of allowing other things
to be inflicted on them punishment is a
compromise with revenge in its natural
state when the ladder is still
maintained and claimed as a privilege by
powerful clowns punishment is a
declaration of war and a war measure
against an enemy of peace of the law of
order
the authorities whom is a danger to the
community as one who's broken the
contract that defines the conditions
under which it exists as a rebel traitor
and breaker of the peace one opposes
with the means of war so you know you
see about nine or ten different possible
ends or reasons or purposes for
punishment being given here these are
all reasons that have been historically
provided by people trying to explain why
they're punishing in this particular
case or or in general so and each you
would say you know to the question well
which one of these is the true purpose
of punishment well they all are they can
all be the purposes of punishment any
one of them can work for that because
we've misunderstood what it is for a
thing to have a purpose in that sense he
would say so if we go back and we think
about the origin of punishment then we
get a better understanding of what's
going on so what is the origin of
punishment in each of thanks and here
he's doing some sort of speculation
about human prehistory but do you know
he's pretty well equipped to do this
since he was a philologist study student
of ancient languages and that meant not
just like learning the vocabulary but
actually reading all the literature and
thinking about that literature as much
as possible so the original relation he
thinks involved in punishment is the
relationship between creditor and debtor
and in ancient times if you went into
debt you pledged things against your
debt and it wasn't like here today where
you can go bankrupt if you went bankrupt
in ancient times you became part of the
debt your family became part of the debt
not just your possessions not just your
money not just your land not just your
house you could be sold into slavery
people could do things to you as part of
demanding repayment on the debt so he he
talks about
punishment itself is in a sense a way of
paying something back a way of
establishing equivalences you are you've
done this sort of thing you've taken
this sort of thing from me I get to take
this from you or I get to impose and in
return this thing upon you there's an
equivalence that's going on with that
now you know do you have to have this
like enshrined in laws courts in a whole
society no this can be between
individuals this can be within a clan a
tribe something like that not
necessarily enshrined worked out on the
spot the whole idea is that equivalences
are being imposed or demanded so well
like he says and this is in Chapter four
of the second second essay the idea now
so obvious apparently so natural even
unavoidable that had to serve as the
explanation of how the sense of justice
ever appeared on earth justice is tied
in with punishment EMDR you punishing
for the right reason he says that is in
fact an extremely late in subtle form of
human human judgment and inference
whoever transposes it to the beginning
whoever is saying that that's the origin
of why people were punished is guilty of
a crude misunderstanding
he says throughout the greater part of
human history punishment was not imposed
because one held the wrongdoer
responsible for the deed and in the
modern sense you don't actually see if
you look at ancient tax ancient writings
ancient discussions of this sort of
stuff you don't actually see very often
the sentiment that well that person
could have done otherwise and so that's
why we're punishing them because they
could have gone this way they could have
gone this way and like a jerk they chose
to go this way instead the person is
being punished more like you know well
things went this way so now you're going
to get what's coming to you over here he
says
not on the presupposition that only the
guilty ones should be punished rather
here we have effects involved rather as
parents still punish their children from
anger at some harm or injury vented on
the one who caused it but this anger is
held in check this is what makes it
punishment rather than just straight out
you know rage or revenge and modified by
the idea that every injury has its
equivalent and can actually be paid back
if only through suffering or pain of the
culprit so we have several different
effects already in play here we have
anger involved anger takes place when
somebody feels that they had been
wronged something has been taken away
from them something has been blocked
something you know something which they
are owed hasn't been given back to them
punishment allows the person who's been
angered to inflict pain or suffering on
the person who's being punished but only
so far only to a certain extent that's
where this this issue of you know
creditor-debtor were exchanged or
measure comes in and so he says you know
this idea of equivalence between injury
and pain have already divulged it in the
contractual relation between creditor
and debtor which as old as the idea of
legal subjects and in turn points back
to the fundamental forms of buying
selling barter trade and traffic these
very very primeval human activities you
might say you know human beings are not
only the animals that reason and that's
part of how we are distinct from other
animals we are the animals that impose
measure we are the animals who swap
things back and forth who make deals
so punishment is tied in with that now
what is the compensation that's being
given at that I mean it could be a
damage a certain amount of your goods I
pay you back that that amount right a
monetary compensation but Nietzsche is
pointing out something very important
here it says when we contemplate these
contractual relationships one of the
things that we noticed is that we see a
lot of severity cruelty and
why is that is it just because you know
order discipline had to be imposed on
these subjects these human beings would
otherwise do whatever they wanted to and
so you had to make it as painful as
possible to burn it into the memory not
exactly in niches view there's something
else underlying this and that has to do
with these effects these feelings these
these desires he says let's be clear as
to the logic of the form of compensation
the logic underlying why it is that the
angered person the wrong person gets to
impose pain or suffering on the other
person she says an equivalence is
provided by the creditors receiving in
place of a literal compensation for an
injury so not in terms of money land
possessions of any kind a recompense in
a form of something else now what is
that something else he says a recompense
in form of enjoyment of pleasure what
kind of pleasure pleasure in hurting
another being pleasure in imposing
conditions on another being in taking
something away for them for example
their freedom in making them do certain
things it's a kind of pleasure a kind of
enjoyment a kind of desire that
Nietzsche thinks is at the root of all
living things insofar as they're living
and in particular human beings he causes
the will to power and we'll talk about
that in just a moment and how that fits
in so he says what is this pleasure more
specifically the pleasure of being
allowed to vent his power freely upon
one who is powerless so placing oneself
above the other forcing the other into a
lower position the voluptuous pleasure
to fear the mall or the player to the
fear so that's a French expression that
he's using there and it means to do harm
to do wrong to do evil to somebody
the malas it can mean all those
different things
for the very enjoyment the pleasure of
doing it this is what we would call in
some respect sadism the enjoyment of
violation the enjoyment of transgressing
another another thing transgressing
boundaries transgressing borders
transgressing relationships he also
notes another thing this enjoyment will
be the greater the lower that the
creditor stands in the social order so
if the creditor is a lower person in the
social order especially if they're able
to punish somebody who's higher up now
they go all the way to the top and
they're forcing that person down so the
the amount of enjoyment comes out of one
social status to a certain extent why is
that he says in punishing the debtor the
creditor participates in the right of
the Masters so it's a way to have power
over people and you know if you think
about this you can see this at work in
every day things go to a restaurant and
sit around and watch people interact
with their servers some people are
decent people and treat them well other
people treat their servers as if they
are servants and they treat them badly
and when the server's maybe screw up or
don't maybe they don't even screw up
perhaps it's the cook or somebody like
that they take it out on them and
they're able to do that in part because
they they have a sense that they are
owning the other person they have a
sense that they're making that person
give them something and if the proof the
server won't fall in line what do they
do they call the manager so that they
can get the manager to help them inflict
what it is that they they want in that
person that's a sort of prosaic example
and you could multiply these by hundreds
so Nietzsche is saying all these
different things are involved so that's
that the origin of punishment what then
does he mean by purposes of punishment
well we skip ahead to chapter 12 and he
says word on the origin and purpose of
punishment to problems that are separate
or ought to be separate
usually they're mixed up now why is he
concerned about them being mixed up well
a lot of people think that if they can
figure out what the purpose of
punishment was or is or ought to be then
they can read that back into history and
they can figure out why we started
punishing in the first place so the
logic behind this is when we come up
with some sort of reason like well we
you know we have to protect society okay
so now we read that back into the origin
and now we know you know why primitive
peoples behaved the way that they did
Nietzsche says it doesn't really work
our purposes may have changed radically
over the time and why would that be well
because they haven't remained constant
in what they were supposed to attain
because it's not the punishment itself
it's not the purpose itself that
dictated it was a will to power in
nature's ideas that determined it so he
says here we go
one imagine that punishment was devised
for punishing but purposes and utilities
usefulness though what you're getting
out of it are only signs that a will to
power has become master of something
less powerful and imposed upon it the
character of a function so if I am in
charge and I am permitted to punish I
may introduce new reasons into why we
punish over time through history and
those are legitimate purposes those are
purposes at least for me i impose them
they may not have been at the origin of
what was going on I introduce something
new to it and I am able to do that
precisely because I force my will on to
somebody else
the one who's being punished perhaps
also the society at large
so I says the entire history of a thing
an organ a custom can in this way
becomes a continuous sign chain of ever
new interpretations and annotations
whose causes don't have to be related to
each other but succeed and alternate
with each other so the evolution of a
thing is not nature thinks a progress
towards goal towards getting better and
better and better it's not even a
logical progress where you're sort of
working out a concept figuring out well
what does punishment really mean let's
think about this well what we want it to
mean is this if you do that you're just
imposing your will to power and then
sort of pushing it backward onto all of
history and saying all of them should
fall into line with you probably not
going to be very successful in doing
that and he says so here we go to return
to our subject you have to distinguish
two aspects that in it which is
relatively enduring the act the drama
the custom or a certain strict sequence
of procedures that's not the origin
itself that's what the origin brings
about punishing involves hurting
somebody imposing pain on something or
taking something away from somebody
imposing conditions out of them then
there's something that's fluid like he
says the purpose or the meaning the
expectation associated with the
performance what it is that it's
supposed to do and so the meaning of
punishment is something that becomes
entirely contestable and I'm going to
read you a passage is what we're gonna
end with here he says this fluid element
its meaning is a very late condition of
culture so it has to do with the time
that we're currently in late modernity
he says the concept punishment possesses
in fact not one meaning but a whole
synthesis of meanings the previous
history of punishment in general the
history of its employment for the most
various purposes
finally crystallizes into
unity that is hard to disentangle hard
to analyze well and as must be
emphasized especially totally
indefinable so what does that mean that
means that if your theory of punishment
is really about what is punishment in
its essence what is the purpose of
punishment you know what what is the
norm or form to which all other
punishment should should conform
Nietzsche's saying that's a lost cause
so he's really doing something quite
radical here in his his theory of
punishment his theory of punishment is a
rejection of saying punishment is
fundamentally about deterrence Punnett
punishment is fundamentally about
reconciling the offender punishment is
fundamentally about this he's saying
punishment is not fundamentally about
any of those things except maybe at the
start and fundamentally it was about
equivalences and making people pay you
back in suffering that you would enjoy
so he's saying all concepts in which an
entire process is semiotic lee that is
through science concentrated elude
definition only that which has no
history is definable at an earlier
earlier stage this synthesis of meanings
can still be disentangled as well as
changed one can perceive how in each
individual case the elements undergo a
shift in value and rearrange them
themselves accordingly so that now this
now that element comes to the fore and
dominates at the expense of others and
under certain circumstances one element
for instance he uses the example of
deterrence appears to overcome all the
remaining elements so what are you
saying is you've got a choice if you if
you want to think about punishment you
can look towards its history and that
things are a little bit more clear or
you can look at this myriad of possible
purposes and realize that in no case are
you ever necessarily talking about these
single purpose so any attempt to say
here's what punishment is really about
so therefore we have to have this policy
we have to stop doing this we have to
start doing this is really just you
using your will to power in a disguised
form and pushing that on to other people
may be a dismal view and your in your
perspective but that is what Nietzsche's
viewpoint actually happens to be honest